في عام 76 من القرن الماضي اعاده الولايات
المتحده تسميه برنامجها لتطوير صاروخ
ارجوا الى نظام الدفاع الجوي باتريوت ليتم
نشره عام 84 منظومه الصواريخ باتريوت
بنسختها الاحداث بي اي سي 3 منظومه دفاع
ارض جو تنتقل بسرعه كبيره لاعتراض وتدمير
صواريخ ذات مدد اقل وصواريخ عابره وطائرات
يصنع نظام من قبل شركه ريثيون الامريكيه
وهي صواريخ مواجهه بتقنيه عاليه تعتمد
فيها على نظام رادار ارضي خاص بها ليكشف
الهدف ويتتبعه تتكون من اربعه اجزاء هي
مركبه الرادار وغرفه التحكم وبنصه
الصواريخ اضافه الى الصواريخ نفسها يقوم
نظام رادار الارضي الخاص بالمنظومه بكشف
الهدف وتتبعه في دائره قطرها نحو 80
كيلومترا وهي تمكن الرادار في هذه
المنظومه من رصد 50 هدفا في ان واحد
فالصاروخ مجهز بنظام توجيه للمسار
والتصحيحه وهو قادر على اعتراضي والتفجير
الصواريخ البالسيه وصواريخ كروز وبعض
انواع الطائرات تحتاج منظومه باتريوت الى
تسع ثواني لاطلاق اول صاروخ بعد اكتشاف
التهديد ويمكنها اصابه اهداف جويه على
نطاق 160 كم تستطيع المنظومه اطلاق 16
صاروخا دفعه واحده يبلغ طول الواحد منها
خمسه امتار ويصل وزن بعض النماذج الى 900
كيلوغرام ويحمل راسا متفجرا قد يصل وزنه
الى 90 كغراما في اغسطس 2018 الولايات
المتحده وبولندا اتفاقيه لانشاء مركز
للباتريوت في بولندا عيسى الصواريخ
الباريسيه وتعمل منظومه باتري وتعدت تامين
المجال الجويه في اوروبا الشرقيه وقد حصلت
دول عديده على المنظومه تمتلك نظام
باتريوت للدفاع الجوي حاليا 12 دوله بينها
تايوان واسرائيل وكوريا الجنوبيه يرى
خبراء ان الصواريخ ستقدم للاوكرانيين فتى
النوعيه في البعدين الميداني والرمزي فهل
تشكل الحدوه التي تمتعت بها كليب لدى
واشنطن بعد شهور من مطالبتها بهذه
الصواريخ منعطفا في الحرب الدائره منذ
ازيد من 300 يوم